[Music]  coming to get you Barbara  the only person your gotcha good night  Harvey can I be in the town of Greendale  where it always feels like Halloween  there lived a girl who was half witch  half mortal who on her 16th birthday  would have to choose between two worlds  the witch world of her family and the  human world of her friends and that girl  is me  are you  I can't do this you must  Sabrina you're going to die half-breed  girls girls  that's no big catty [ __ ] no rebel  scum it's our lack my urges  [Music]  I'm not an evil person  but these are desperate times  my name is Sabrina Spellman and I will  not sign it away  would you like to do the honors with  pleasure  rise  three-sixty  he was on Hilda she annoyed me so I  killed her we buried her in the yard  [Music]